Bob discovered something very
interesting while making multicolored
earrings out of beads for his store now
his customers like variety so he decides
to make every possible style for each
size starting with size 3 he begins by
figuring out all possible styles well
each earring begins as a string of beads
and then the ends are attached to form a
ring so first how many possible strings
are there well with two colors and three
beads there are three choices each from
two colors so two times two times two
equals eight possible unique strings and
then he subtracts the strings which have
only one color or mono colored strings
since he's only building multicolored
earrings then he glues them all together
to form rings he was assuming he would
end up with six different earrings but
something happened he can no longer tell
the difference between most of them it
turns out he only has two Styles because
each style is now part of a group with
two identical partners
notice you can always match them up
based on rotations so the size of these
groups must be based on how many
rotations it takes to return to the
original or how many rotations to
complete a cycle
so this means that the original set of
all multicolored strings divides evenly
into groups of size three
hmm now would this be true for other
sizes that would be convenient since he
always wants the same amount of each
style so he tries this with four beads
first he builds all possible strings and
with four beads he can choose from two
colors for each bead so 2 times 2 times
2 times 2 equals 16 then he removes the
two mono colored necklaces and attaches
all of the others to form rings now will
they form equal sized groups
apparently not what happened notice how
the initial set of strings divides into
styles
if strings are of the same style it
means you can form one into the other
simply by grabbing beads from one end
and sticking them on to the other end
and there is one style which only has
two members and this is because it's
built out of a repeating unit of length
two so only two rotations are required
to complete a cycle therefore this group
only contains two he cannot split them
into an equal number of styles
what about size five will they break
into equal number of each style
wait suddenly he realizes he doesn't
even need to build them in order to find
out it must work since five cannot be
made up of a repeating pattern because
five cannot be broken into equal parts
it's a prime number so no matter what
kind of multicolored string you start
with it will always take five rotations
or bead swaps to return to itself the
cycle length of every string must be 5
well let's check first we'll build all
possible strings and remove the two mono
colored strings then we separate the
strings into groups which belong to the
same style and build a single earring
for each style notice that each earring
rotates exactly 5 times to complete a
cycle therefore if we glue all the
strings into rings
they must split into equal sized groups
of 5 but then he goes one step further
currently he is only using two colors
but he realizes this must hold with any
number of colors because any
multicolored earring with a prime number
of beads P must have a cycle length of P
since Prime's cannot be broken into
equal sized units but if a composite
number of beads are used such as six we
will always have certain strings with
shorter cycle lengths since it's
actually built out of a repeating unit
and therefore will form smaller groups
and amazingly he just stumbled on to
form AHS little theorem given a colors
and strings of length P which are prime
the number of possible strings is a
times a times a P times or a ^ P and
when he removed the mono coloured
strings he subtracts exactly a strings
since there are one for each color this
leaves him with a to the power of P
minus a strings
and when he glues these strings together
they will fall into groups of size P
since each earring must have a cycle
length of P therefore P divides a to the
power of P minus a and that's it we can
express this statement in modular
arithmetic to think of it if you divide
a to the power of P by P you will be
left with a remainder a so we can write
this as a to the power of P is congruent
to a mod P and here we have stumbled
onto one of the fundamental results in
number theory merely by playing with
beads